well let's cross live now to our royal
correspondent Rhiannon Mills and
Rhiannon worry your thoughts on seeing
this interview well this was an
extraordinary and explosive interview
that happened right at the heart of the
British monarchy inside Buckingham
Palace over 45 minutes the Duke of York
answering the most intimate questions
about his private life it was for the
first time that he spoke on camera about
those allegations from Virginia Roberts
he denies meeting her he also drew into
question whether or not the photograph
that or them together was in fact fake
and he also said that it couldn't
possibly have happened because he
doesn't sweat because he has a medical
condition but I think what is most
damaging for the Duke is the fact that
on two separate occasions he was asked
whether or not he regrets that
friendship with Jeffrey Epstein he
refused to do that he simply talked
about the benefits that that
relationship had in terms of allowing
him to build up important business
contacts over in America there continued
to be many questions this evening for
example if he wasn't close friends with
Jeffrey Epstein why did he really feel
the need to go in 2010 to cut off that
relationship even though he said it was
the honorable thing to do I think also
there'll be many especially over in
America who would have wanted to see him
showing some kind of sympathy towards
the victims instead when asked what he
would say to Virginia Roberts he said
that he simply had to have thick skin
when it came to dealing with those
allegations now I think while we all
pick over whether or not this was a risk
too far from a palace perspective it was
the right time from the princes
perspective it was the right time that
we heard in his own words what he had to
say about those allegations but I think
in essence what this simply does is
really opens up him up to yet more
scrutiny about that relationship between
him and convicted pedophile Jeffrey
Epstein